Siempre pensamos que en estas
versiones idealizadas, la gente muestra lo mejor
que le ha pasado en su vida. Muchas veces he pensado así.
Mis amigos, no pueden ser tan geniales y tener tan buena vida.
Bien, un estudio probó esto examinando las personalidades de la gente.
Cuatro buenos amigos del individuo debían juzgar su personalidad.
Luego muchos desconocidos, tenían que
juzgar su personalidad a través de Facebook,
y lo que se descubrió fue que los juicios de la personalidad
eran prácticamente idénticos, altamente correlacionados,
lo que significa que los perfiles de Facebook realmente reflejan nuestra verdadera personalidad.
Bien, ¿qué decir de las citas en línea?
Es decir, es un ambiente que se presta bastante para el engaño.
Estoy seguro de que todos Uds. tienen "amigos" que han utilizado citas en línea. (Risas)
Y te deben haber contado del tipo que no tenía pelo
cuando se presentó, o de la mujer que no se parecía en absoluto a su foto.
Bien, esto nos interesaba realmente, así que
trajimos personas que hacen citas en línea, al laboratorio,
y luego los medimos. Tomamos su altura
contra la pared, los pusimos en una balanza, obtuvimos su peso
—a las señoras les encantó— y les pedimos la licencia de conducir para saber su edad.
Y lo que descubrimos fue muy, muy interesante.
Aquí hay un ejemplo de los hombres y la altura.
En la parte inferior está la altura que ellos declararon en su perfil.
En el eje vertical, tenemos la altura real.
Esa línea diagonal es la línea de la verdad. Si el punto está sobre ella
decían exactamente la verdad.
Ahora, como pueden ver, la mayoría de los puntos está por debajo de la línea.
Lo cual significa que todos los hombres han mentido sobre su altura.
De hecho, mintieron sobre su altura en poco más de 2,3 cm,
lo que en el laboratorio llamamos "fuerte redondeo hacia arriba". (Risas)
Mides casi 1,73 m y ¡bum!, 1,75 m.
Pero lo que es realmente importante aquí es, miren todos esos puntos.
Se agrupan bastante cerca de la verdad. Lo que descubrimos
fue que el 80% de nuestros participantes mintió
sobre una de esas dimensiones, pero siempre mentían por poco.
Una de las razones es bastante simple. Si acudes a una cita,
a tomar un café y eres completamente diferente a lo que dijiste ser,
se terminó ¿no? Entonces las personas mintieron con frecuencia, pero mintieron
sutilmente, no demasiado. Se contuvieron.
Bien, ¿qué explican todos estos estudios? ¿Cómo se explica el hecho de
que a pesar de nuestra intuición, incluso la mía,
mucha de la comunicación en línea, a través de un medio tecnológico,
sea más honesta que la comunicación cara a cara?
Es realmente extraño. ¿Cómo podemos explicar esto?
Bueno, para ello, podemos observar la literatura de detección del engaño.
Es una literatura muy antigua, surgió hace 50 años.
Ha sido revisada varias veces. Ha habido miles de ensayos,
cientos de estudios, y hay algunos resultados realmente convincentes.
El primero es que somos bastante malos para la detección del engaño,
realmente malos. 54% de exactitud, en promedio cuando se trata de decir
si alguien que acaba de hacer una declaración está mintiendo o no.
Eso es muy malo. ¿Por qué es tan malo?
Bueno, tiene que ver con la nariz de Pinocho.
Si les preguntara a Uds., ¿de qué fiarse
cuando miran a alguien y quieren averiguar
si está mintiendo? ¿A qué indicio deben prestar atención?
La mayoría de Uds. diría que una señal a tener en cuenta
son los ojos. Los ojos son la ventana del alma.
Y Uds. no serían los únicos. En todo el mundo, en casi todas las culturas,
una de las claves principales son los ojos. Pero la investigación
durante los últimos 50 años, dice que no hay realmente ninguna señal confiable
para detectar el engaño, lo que me ha sorprendido, y es una de
las duras lecciones que aprendí cuando era funcionario de aduana.
Los ojos no nos dicen si alguien está mintiendo o no.
En algunas situaciones, sí, cuando el riesgo es alto, tal vez las pupilas se dilaten,
el tono de voz sube y los movimientos corporales cambien un poco,
pero no siempre, ni para todos. No es algo confiable.
Extraño. Además solo porque no puedas verme
no significa que voy a mentir. Es de sentido común,
pero un hallazgo importante es que mentimos por alguna razón.
Mentimos para protegernos, en nuestro propio beneficio
o en el de alguien más.
Hay mentirosos patológicos, pero representan
una pequeña parte de la población. Mentimos por alguna razón.
El hecho de que la gente no pueda vernos no significa
necesariamente que vayamos a mentir.
Pero creo que en realidad hay algo mucho más
interesante y fundamental que pasa aquí.
La próxima gran idea, podemos encontrarla yendo
atrás en la historia hasta los orígenes del lenguaje.
La mayoría de los lingüistas coincide en que empezamos a hablar en alguna parte
entre 50 000 y 100 000 años atrás. Eso es mucho tiempo.
Gran cantidad de seres humanos ha vivido desde entonces.
Hemos estado hablando, me imagino, sobre fuegos, cuevas
y tigres dientes de sable. No sé de qué hablaban,
pero hablaban mucho, y como he dicho,
fue enorme la cantidad de seres humanos que hizo evolucionar el habla,
alrededor de 100 mil millones de personas.
Lo importante sin embargo es que la escritura solo surgió
hace unos 5000 años. Lo cual significa que
todas las personas anteriores a la aparición de la escritura,
cada palabra que hayan dicho, toda expresión,
desapareció. Sin rastro. Se evanesció. Se fue.
Así que hemos evolucionado para hablar de una manera en
la que no hay registro. De hecho, el siguiente gran cambio
a la escritura se produjo hace solo 500 años,
con la imprenta, que es bastante reciente en nuestro pasado,
y las tasas de alfabetización permanecieron muy bajas hasta la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
por lo que incluso la gente de los dos últimos milenios,
la mayoría de las palabras que han dicho - ¡puf! - desaparecieron.
Pasemos al presente, la era de Internet.
¿Cuántos de Uds. han grabado algo hoy?
¿Alguien ha escrito algo hoy? ¿Alguien escribió alguna palabra?
Parece que casi todos aquí han grabado algo.
En esta sala, ahora mismo, probablemente hemos registrado más
que casi toda la prehistoria de la humanidad.
Es una locura. Estamos entrando en un período increíble
de cambio continuo en la evolución humana por el que hemos pasado de hablar
de una manera en que nuestras palabras desaparecen,
a un entorno en el que estamos grabando todo.
De hecho, creo que en un futuro muy próximo, no solo
se grabará lo que escribimos, todo lo que hacemos
será registrado.
¿Qué significa eso? ¿Cuál es la próxima gran idea?
Bien, como científico social, esto es lo más asombroso
que ni siquiera he soñado. Ahora, puedo mirar
a todas estas palabras que durante milenios desaparecieron.
Puedo observar las mentiras que primero fueron dichas y luego desaparecieron.
¿Recuerdan esos comentarios de "astroturfing" de los que
hablamos antes? Bueno, cuando se escribe una reseña falsa,
tiene que publicarse en algún lugar, quedando a nuestra disposición.
Algo que hicimos y les daré un ejemplo
en relación con el habla, es que le pagamos a la gente
para escribir algunas opiniones falsas. Uno de estos comentarios es falso.
La persona nunca estuvo en el Hotel James.
El otro comentario es real. La persona estuvo allí.
Ahora, la tarea de Uds. es decidir
cuál de ellos es falso.
Les daré un momento para leerlos.
Pero quiero que levanten la mano en determinado momento.
Recuerden, yo estudio el engaño. Me daré cuenta si no levantan la mano.
Bien, ¿cuántos de Uds. creen que "A" es el comentario falso?
Muy bien. Muy bien. Aproximadamente la mitad.
Y ¿cuántos de Uds. piensan que "B" lo es?
Muy bien. Un poco más para "B".
Excelente. Aquí está la respuesta.
"B" es el falso. Bien hecho segundo grupo. Le ganaron al primer grupo. (Risas)
En realidad es un poco inusual. Cada vez que hacemos esta demostración,
normalmente la división es de 50-50, lo cual concuerda
con la investigación, 54%. Tal vez la gente aquí
en Winnipeg sea más suspicaz y más hábil para darse cuenta.
Esos inviernos fríos, rigurosos, me encantan.
Muy bien, ¿por qué me interesa esto?
Bueno, con mis colegas informáticos
creamos algoritmos que analizan
las huellas lingüísticas del engaño.
Permítanme destacar un par de cosas
sobre el comentario falso. La primera es que los mentirosos ponen el foco
en la narrativa. Inventan un relato:
¿Quién? ¿Y qué pasó? Y eso fue lo que pasó aquí.
Nuestros falsos opinadores contaron con quién estaban
y lo que estaban haciendo. También utilizaban la primera persona del singular, "yo",
en mayor medida que las personas que realmente estuvieron allí.
Fueron introduciéndose en los comentarios sobre el hotel,
como tratando de convencerte de que estuvieron allí.
Por el contrario, la gente que dejó comentarios habiendo estado realmente allí,
los que en realidad ingresaron en el espacio físico,
dieron mucha más información referida al espacio.
Dijeron de qué tamaño era el baño,
o la distancia a la que estaba el centro comercial.
Ahora, Uds. lo hicieron bastante bien. La mayoría prueban suerte con esta tarea.
Nuestro algoritmo es muy preciso, mucho más preciso
que los seres humanos, pero no siempre lo será.
No se trata de un detector de mentiras que dice
si tu novia te está mintiendo en los mensajes de texto.
Creemos que la mentira, cualquier tipo de mentira
—opiniones falsas de hoteles, de calzados,
de tu novia engañándote con mensajes de texto—
son mentiras diferentes. Van a tener
diferentes patrones de lenguaje. Pero como ahora todo
queda registrado, podemos analizar esas mentiras.
Como he dicho, como científico social, esto es una maravilla.
Es transformacional. Seremos capaces de aprender
mucho más sobre el pensamiento humano y la expresión,
sobre cualquier materia desde el amor a las actitudes,
porque ahora todo se registra, pero,
¿qué significado tiene para el ciudadano común?
¿Qué significa en nuestras vidas?
Bueno, dejemos un poco de lado el engaño. Una de las grandes ideas,
creo, es que estamos dejando enormes rastros detrás nuestro.
Mi buzón de salida de correo electrónico es enorme,
y nunca me fijo. Escribo todo el tiempo,
pero nunca me fijo en los rastros que quedan.
Y creo que vamos a ver mucho más de eso,
en que podamos reflexionar sobre quiénes somos mirando
lo que escribimos, lo que dijimos, lo que hicimos.
Ahora, volviendo al tema del engaño, hay un par
de cosas para resaltar.
En primer lugar, mentir en línea puede ser muy peligroso, ¿verdad?
No solo queda un registro de ti mismo en tu máquina,
también estás dejando un registro en la persona a quien le estabas mintiendo
y además los estás dejando para que yo los analice
con algunos algoritmos de computación.
Así que por supuesto, sigue adelante y hazlo, está bien.
Pero cuando se trata de la mentira y lo que queremos hacer
con nuestras vidas, creo que podemos volver a
Diógenes y Confucio. Estaban menos preocupados
sobre mentir o no mentir y más preocupados por
el ser fiel a sí mismo, y creo que esto es realmente importante.
Ahora, cuando estén a punto de decir o hacer algo,
podemos pensar, "¿quiero que esto sea parte de mi legado,
de mi expediente personal?"
Porque en la era digital que vivimos ahora,
en la era de la red, todos estamos dejando un registro.
Muchas gracias por su tiempo,
y buena suerte con su registro. (Aplausos)